hello rejects nation's drag outta here
Meghan length over here career
gotten a lot of requests from this
especially from couple people on patreon
Swedish dicks official trailer
it's a Papas No thank God you didn't
maybe there's a couple characters named
Richard in here Oh
I mean restricted mode YouTube don't
don't don't harp on me right now Jack
this is this a TV series it might just
be a mini seriously as it says it starts
Keanu Reeves and Peter Stormare who you
might not know the name honor but when
you see him you'll recognize him as a
guy who plays a lot of Russian bad guys
did you see John with - yeah remember
the beginning of John wick - the guy
who's like setting up John wick and he
and John wake has a shot of vodka with
him yeah he's always a Russian bagging
he plays he's in Armageddon there he's
not a bad guy throw that out there the
one the one rope yeah Los Angeles
California the land of sunshine and
laughing we could living as a private
investigators
it's liver easy like that I think I got
heart attacks you're such a drama queen
[Music]
domina these bars with words mouth and
slice are using sure are these dinner is
bound behind us we have admit we're good
people
you're extremely annoyed why are you
testing all of the downsides of being a
private is to make a lot of enemies you
want the truth I'll give you the truth I
am firing you know I don't find you
physically attractive right no I didn't
but I do now we all have to find our
place in the universe
you've even need to miss rolled up
traffic through the rain a dead human
body and throw it in the ocean
- no no - being team player no is not
goanna Chitti more
[Music]
[Music]
how do you feel about that top TV first
talk to you and never to Papa I don't
know that it what do you think of it the
comedy makes me think of the zombie
movies that are fighting the British
zombie those zombie movies it's the
British comedian so yeah I kind of make
you think of that we kind of like banter
or the rhythm what is it I don't know do
you agree I can kind of see what you're
talking about there's a sort of type of
rhythm and vibe to it it's grounded and
reasoned like a sort of heightened
reality yeah these guys who are in a
serious position but they don't behave
so serious about letting they're in good
cause I could thanks I've done enough
videos to kind of make some grammar
correctly I'm like your professional
profession on it he made like you Peter
Stormare well one thing I'm happy this
guy is doing a role that's not Russian
bad guy because these so typecast is
that in so many movies and it's cool
they have a lead role in something where
you know this this could be a role that
he actually gets known for it might
actually know his name because I feel
like a lot of the time you see him and
mostly brother I've seen that guy in a
movie before he's done so many films but
his name's not seven own and I'm
wondering what makes he on Reeves drawn
yeah yes and it's nice to see him doing
a role was loosening up a lot mm-hmm
is such a silly it's such a silly
concept this whole thing yes though he
seems like the straight guy in this yeah
he seems like he's having fun with the
roll at the same times I have to which
I'm happy to see maybe they became just
such great friends off the one day of
shooting they did on the other way
chapter 2 but he said sure I'll be a
part of it maybe they came up with it on
set alright so that's true love a big
blooper big big
well I mean this just games big beam so
I figured that's great times you know
being a similarly so I mean the concepts
I'll write to me private investigator
Hollywood I like words like that the
nice guys right I don't see enough shows
that really provide the grid in the
dirtiness of Hollywood and I think Holly
was a rather dirty place in a lot of a
lot of ways at the same time there's no
I gotta be honest or something about the
shows is doesn't really truly hooked me
it does the trailer didn't do it in a
form where I'm like I have to tune in
the only as made me to want to tune in
is I really enjoy watching Keanu
reinvest whether or not he does a good
job I still will want to watch it and he
doesn't look like he's doing great in
this role but on my resume I check him
out on TV show or not what happens when
he's not like jumping and kicking and
punching engineer right what did he do
what is what women are drawn to this I
got it I just got to find that out but
the Peter Stormare character I get it
it's called Swedish dick so it kind of
has this like bro kind of mean humor
about it your guys having a heart attack
you're calling him a drama queen
he seems like very self-centered and I
and I could get on board for a character
like that I can enjoy a show at the same
time there's nothing here about an that
really looks that likable it just looks
like it looks like a dick and maybe
that's the point but I maybe is that
hero you love to hate maybe you know
there's certain shows were like the
characters kind of a dick and I like
them here I'm not really seeing what the
big draw is our Swedish known to be
friendly a little bit like I do hold
millions of the Swedish people I wanna
be friendly and make me good friends
yeah that's true I'm sure this is
probably like a John wick prequel maybe
maybe this is what led into Peter
Stormare character being in Jonah
chapter 2 how neat of a the thing that
would actually we were all wondering
when we thought yeah that's right
hey guy get here calories is a very
specific John wick look the hair and the
facial hair yeah and he has these
rocking that exact look here too like
straight had a job
holding the gun in the trailer talking
menacing on a phone
tall job I think Peter summarized
actually Swedish you may plays Russian
bag either long yeah you know you know
your Swedish language right yeah yeah
what's pop pop television let's look it
up let's see what shows they have [ __ ]
creek and her - it's crank then they run
they run reruns in like Beverly Hills
that's not as Creek er interesting that
but why do what is this yet I've never
heard of this how did you Keanu Reeves
to be this might be the first show
they're promoting where people are like
I gotta get pop television now just to
see what this is about
I just like to see a little bit more I
probably give the pilot a chance the
main hook they're doing to get people to
see it is probably getting Keanu Reeves
in there right
I I doubt that Keanu Reeves is the main
character and I doubt he's gonna be in
the show the entire run I'm sure it's
just a reoccurring character they got to
agree to be a part of a few episodes
there's no way Keanu Reeves going to
suddenly switch to a supporting for the
business the art or the money yeah yeah
so has to be the art in this yeah and
I'm wondering how edgy the humor
actually is sometimes the raunchiness
seems a little forced or like the edgy
kind of r-rated jokes seem a little
force and they don't seem as like
authentic to what it actually is maybe
I'm just being too hard on two minutes
of a trailer of a show that has a lot
more hours the two minutes of it who
knows maybe I'll check it out do you
think you'll check it out I think you're
going to buy pop TV start off that is a
free trial but I look over to your house
and wash everything let's do it
movie your show right Yes Swedish people
are on the rise now different they need
a need a hop on board the diversity
training we want to get in on the
diverse though
everybody like never rabbit anomaly
where are you guys going to watch a
Swedish dicks show are you gonna get
your hot television subscription
activities back subscriber already is
that like five days we got the right
hand I can even click that notification
valve Megan Lai Megan laughs Graham and
Twitter to go follow her there
badass actions future star that's the
word grammatical correctness put it
right there go check her out you'll see
it's worth your time and yeah go check
out our patreon if it seems worth it to
you